so we've all wondered when it would
happen well it's happening
state officials confirming tonight that
the vanna will loosen up its capacity
limits next week
orco mana joining us now live with more
on what's going to be changing
well denise starting at 12 a.m this
coming monday venues across the state
can have up to 50 capacity or 250 people
whichever is less
and from restaurants to performers
everyone we spoke to
is excited there's more heads in the
room and that
that translates into good business
cranking up the cap on customers
capacity limits across nevada are going
from 35 to 50 percent
starting monday that means about 60
people can dine at table 34.
just kind of filling our real estate
more efficiently
we first met executive chef wes kendrick
in may 2020 as the restaurant prepared
for its first reopening amid covet 19.
and keeping everybody socially distant
it also
eliminates a number of table tops now
ten months later even though plexiglass
and sanitizer are still front and center
more seats are being added we still have
them socially distant so i think
i think that's reasonable and it's a
step in the right direction we're very
much looking forward to it capacities
increasing
also good news for local performers like
the soldiers band
our doing well is dependent on the venue
doing well
lead singer david tatlock telling me
venues now find it more economically
feasible to let them play and their
first
in-person show in over a year is set for
april we're all trying to make it work
the venue owners the performers
and just get back to doing some of the
things we love and the music we love
the goal for everyone is to keep moving
forward i'm hoping
at least by summer that we get back to
normal capacity
the state also just announced that
starting monday if an organizer wants to
host an event
with more than 250 people they can now
do so and make it
about 50 capacity but that's only if
that organizer
submits a safety plan to the department
of business and industry
and if that plan gets approved reporting
live in las vegas tonight orco mana 8
news now